That's one of the most important
lessons in Jacob Mchangama's new
book "Free Speech: A History
From Socrates to Social Media."
Mchangama heads up the Danish
think tank Justicia.
He's worried about a proposal that
would make hate speech a crime under
European Union law and give
bureaucrats in Brussels sweeping
powers to prosecute people spewing
venom at religious and ethnic
minorities. Members of the LGBT
plus community, women and others.
Europe's history with such laws
argues against them.
In the 1920s, Germany's viremia
republic strictly regulated
the press and invoked emergency
powers to crack down on Nazi speech.
It censored and prosecuted the
editor of the anti-Semitic Nazi
paper Der Sturmer Julius Streicher,
who used his trial as a platform
for spreading his views and his
imprisonment as a way of turning
himself into a martyr and his cause
into a crusade.
When the Nazis took power in the
early thirties, they expanded
existing laws and precedents
to shut down dissent and freedom of
assembly. Contemporary scholarship
suggests that there can be a
backlash effect when government shut
down speech, leading otherwise
moderate people to embrace fringe
beliefs. Mchangama points
to a 2017 study published
in the European Journal of Political
Research that concluded extremism
in Western Europe was fueled in part
by extensive public repression
of radical right actors and
opinions.
In 1965, the United Kingdom
passed a law banning incitement
to racial hatred.
But one of the very first people
prosecuted under it was a black
Briton who called whites vicious
and nasty people in a speech.
More recently, Mchangama notes that
radical feminists in England
have been charged with offending
LGBT+ people because
they insist there are biological
differences between the sexes.
In France and LGBT+
rights organization was fined for
calling an opponent of same sex
marriage a homophobe.
Once the principle of free speech is
abandoned, warns Mchangama, any
minority can end up being targeted
rather than protected by laws
against hatred and offense.
That's what happened in Canada in
the 1990s, after the Supreme Court
there ruled that words and images
that degrade women could be banned.
The decision was based in part on
the legal theories of Andrea
Dworkin, whose books on why
pornography should be banned were
briefly seized by Canadian customs
agents under the laws she
helped to inspire.
First Amendment rights are still
very popular in the United States,
with 91 percent of us in
a recent survey agreeing that
protecting free speech is an
important part of American
democracy.
But fully 60 percent of us
said that the government should
prohibit people from sharing of
racist or bigoted idea, hearing
hateful words and ideas, outrages
and discomforts most of us.
But Mission Gama's history of free
speech underscores that state
suppression can grant those
words and ideas more power and
influence, and that the best
antidote to hate in a free and
open society is not to hide
from it, but to loudly and
persuasively confront it.